ce que l'on a appelé la sphère grégory
aborde aujourd'hui un nouveau tournant
avec le renvoi en cour d'assises de
christine villemin autrement dit la
chambre d'accusation de la cour d'appel
de nancy a estimé que le dossier
d'instruction était bouclé et que le
procès pourrait avoir lieu
christine villemin et son avocat avaient
espéré un supplément d'information
patricia en tout cas si la cour de
cassation confirme la décision de renvoi
devant la cour d'assises
christine villemin sera la première mère
accusée d'infanticide à se présenter
devant les jurés en prévenu libre elle
est inculpé depuis juillet 1985 pour
l'assassinât de son fils marcel trillât
le président de la chambre d'accusation
de la cour d'appel de nancy monsieur vox
thème perget et ses deux assesseurs
viennent de trancher
christine villemin est renvoyé devant
les assises son avocat maître garraud
qui avait demandé il y à un mois un
supplément d'information n'aura donc pas
été suivi
cet arrêt ne saurait constituer une
déclaration de culpabilité
il laisse d'ailleurs en suspens de
nombreuses et importantes questions
posées notamment celle du mobile
malheureusement le calvaire judiciaire
de christine villemin continue et
prolonger la détention de jean marie
un arrêt attendu par la partie civile
mais accueillie sans triomphalisme
nous attirons votre attention sur le
fait que nous sommes nous très attaché
aux principes christine villemin
bénéficie de la présomption d'innocence
et nous pensons que jusqu'au procès il
faut respecter la forme la chambre
d'accusation de nancy n'a pas statué sur
l'innocence ou sur sa culpabilité
les avocats de la défense ont maintenant
cinq jours et se pourvoir en cassation
si le pourvoi n'est pas rejeter ce sera
au tour de la haute juridiction des
peluches et pas mal de l'ombre le
dossier du juge gerber encadrent auger
ce sont les neuf jurés de la cour
d'assises devront dire en leur âme et
conscience si festive villemin a
effectivement assassiné grégory son
enfant de 4 ans en le noyant dans la
vologne
un après-midi d'octobre 1995 une tâche
accablante
compte tenu des innombrables
imperfections d'une enquête souvent
brouillonnes dans le dossier pourtant
quelques éléments qui constituent de
graves présomptions
d'abord les expertises en écriture elles
sont convergentes les lettres du corbeau
qui harcelait la famille villemin
pendant des années ce serait bien de la
main de christine surtout la dernière
celle qui annonce la mort de l'enfant et
qui est expédié quelques minutes avant
le crime le 16 octobre 1984
quatre camarades de travail de christine
villemin affirme justement l'avoir vu ce
jour là peu avant 17 heures déposé une
lettre à la poste de lépanges mais il ya
aussi le doute
aucun témoin des phénomènes aucun mobile
et le laps de temps extrêmement réduits
pendant lequel cette jeune mère aurait
pu accomplir avec un sang froid et une
détermination hors du commun
un tel acte